[Music]
it's been 31 years since Mario hopped
onto arcade screens in Donkey Kong and
everyone's favorite portly plumber shows
no signs of slowing down his latest
adventure super mario odyssey brings him
to the Nintendo switch where once again
Princess Peach has been kidnapped by
Bowser and little ole Mario needs to
save the day
Nintendo has put in so little gameplay
mechanisms that help you on your quest
to get power moons both obvious ones and
hidden ones some of these systems are
explained in game but they may be easy
to miss while others are left a bit
vague we've put together a collection of
tips that will give you a little leg up
and get you skipping on your way to
rescuing Peach when you first get the
game spend some time jumping around
Mario's basic jump is perfect for
crossing small gaps and pouncing on
enemies but he has a wide range of tools
that are absolutely essential for games
trickier platforming moments you'll need
to have mastery of all these abilities
to find most of the moons Mario's jumps
can be modified by jumping repeatedly
using specific timing but a stomping
before you jump or leaping by crouching
before you jump these moves along with
most of his others are easy to pull off
once you're comfortable with them but
you'll want to practice so executing
them is second nature
capi the sentient hat accompanying Mario
in Odyssey is primarily used for taking
control of enemies or objects but you
can also use them to extend jumps we
suggest learning their hat throw and
leap combo as it's undoubtedly one of
the most useful moves in the game jump
in the air and throw capi then keep the
button held down to have Cappy hover a
moment while the Hat is spinning hit
crouch and jump and you'll leap forward
and launch back into the air this can be
repeat the second time to gain even more
ground thankfully mario odyssey features
an action guide where all the advanced
moves are available for you to read
about on top of that cappy will remind
you about things you can do when you're
traveling between worlds pick up coins
it can be tempting to skip a few coins
in the distance when you're running
around but coins have more value than
ever before in Odyssey instead of using
a traditional life system where each
theft counts down to a game over screen
all you see Nixon
from Mario's deep pockets there's no
punishment for dining with zero coins
but it does mean that you'll have less
to spend on goodies coins are also used
to buy things from various shops
scattered around all of these worlds
each shop usually has a top up of hearts
on offer as well as a moon that was
looking to get every single moon in the
game we'll want to be especially
diligent about grabbing coins as more
moons become available to purchase from
shops later in the game of course coins
are also used to purchase new outfits
for Mario and you have to purchase the
hat and jumpsuit portions separately and
trust us you'll want all of them they
don't change the way Mario plays by
adding abilities but it's pretty darn
cool to see him dressed up as a cowboy
or a racecar driver to fly to a new
location your ship needs a certain
amount of moose to power it and the game
denotes the recommended amount on screen
the simplest way to find easy to just
play through each world and keep your
eyes peeled for them as many are visible
along the main path however if you're
going for the full moon completion
you'll need to explore as there's quite
a few hidden away behind puzzles
thankfully when you complete an area by
being a boss hint toad will appear near
the Odyssey as the name implies hint
told will mark the location of a moon on
your map for 50 coins which is very
useful you might think that's a bit of a
cheat but it's still quite tricky to get
these moons as indicators are just a
vague hint of where they are for those
that need a little extra guidance they
stalker to a loose lip wide jaw parity
that hangs around the main hub of each
area chat to talk or to and it will tell
you the name of the Moon which usually
provides some further insight into where
they are or what you need to do to grab
them bear in mind that there's a limit
to how many times you can use hint toad
and torpor to moon's make a little
twinkling sound when you're close by
on your travels around the world make
sure to keep your ears open as well as
your eyes pealed it can be easy to set
your sight on a moon on the main path
and focus on it but you'll often find
that there are extra months tucked away
behind secret walls or place just out of
view another way to find hidden moons or
coins is through control of vibrations
this one is much trickier as running
around usually also makes the controller
vibrate just a little bit
however the feedback should be stronger
when you're near a secret I am a lo of
goodies hidden underground usually have
a shaft of colorful light to draw your
attention to them but this isn't always
the case so pay attention to those
vibrations a more delightful way of
finding hidden items is to let the
adorable little Nintendogs sniff them
out for you you'll find him very early
in the game chilling out in a shop in
the desert world but after you complete
that world he'll venture out when you
see him he'll excitedly bark at you and
run off into the distance give chase and
he'll lead you to something good in turn
dog will appear in other locations
during your journey so keep an eye out
for him and once he's found something
for you why not show your appreciation
and play frisbee with him Chuck Cappy at
the puppy from a distance and he'll grab
it in his mouth it's wonderful scattered
around each of oddities words are little
puzzle rooms they're accessed by finding
doors with little hats on them or by
jumping down the iconic green pipes each
of these rooms will test your mastery of
platforming or ask you to possess an
enemy using Kathy and then use their
unique abilities to solve a puzzle or
reach areas inaccessible to Mario in his
tiny human form the extra secret with
these rooms is they usually have more
than one moon hiding within them this
isn't the case a hundred percent of the
time but it pays to go into each one
with the mindset that there's more than
meets the eye in there be extra vigilant
when running through them and take the
time to stop frequently and spin the
camera around a bit you'll often find a
moon is only visible if you're looking
at it from a specific angle if that
wasn't enough keep your eyes out for
little Rockets by getting over to these
and then throwing capping on them you
can blast off into the clouds and into
more secret areas where naturally even
more moons await when you're flowing
over the planet in Odyssey you can hit
the Y button to bring up stats on each
world this menu has essential
information on all the
available in each location making it
easy to see what you have and what
remains it's a simple touch that makes
getting 100% completion just a little
more manageable
another character in Super Mario odyssey
that's quite useful is uncle amiibo the
little Roomba like device hovering
around near the ship if you're a
collector of Nintendo's amiibo figures
they'll come in very handy as they can
be used to locate stray moons tap your
amiibo on the NFC reader and uncle
amiibo will send it out on a hunt it
takes around five minutes
but once that time is up he'll let you
know where you can find a new moon
there's a limit on how many times you
can use uncle I'm able to find moons so
it's better to use him when you're
really struggling amiibo are also useful
for a little coin injection if you touch
a figure while just out in the world you
can get some coins to add to your purse
this is useful when you're a little
short on funds and want to purchase an
item from the shop for maximum
efficiency get uncle amiibo to send out
three amiibos to hunt for moons then go
out and try and grab some yourself when
you get back there'll be a few more for
you to venture out for this assumes of
course that you have three amiibo if you
don't you can just use the same amiibo
over and over again there you have it
five tips for all you would be plumbers
about to embark on an odyssey Super
Mario Odyssey is a big game and we'll be
digging into a deeper over the coming
days in the meantime you can check out
our video review or head to GameSpot
they'll come to read our full written
review
[Music]